The second way that you can create your body ends up creating an autoimmune disease is if your immune system turns on against something that it was never supposed to turn on to.
And your immune system was never supposed to turn on to inert substances, meaning non-living toxins.
So what are some non-living toxins that if we did a chemical smear of anybody's bone tissue or a joint capsule or neural tissue here would probably have some in?
Heavy metals.
So heavy metals, pesticides, chemicals, fertilizers, I mean there's too many chemicals to mention because they're putting maybe ten more out on the market today.
Those things are going into our food supplies, they're into our breathing space. I mean even, I mean this carpet was not dyed with blueberries and raspberries, I guarantee it.
So those chemicals are leeching. That's why it fades over time. They're leeching into our air space, the fastest way for you to get something into your blood other than injecting it is for you to breathe it in.
So those go into your body, they circulate in your body and your liver has to detox them.
And if your liver is exceeding its ability to get rid of things which happens on a regular basis, then it has to be shunted somewhere or you'll end up with toxemia and it gets shunted to different cells of your body.
So it ends up in the extra cellular spaces, it goes into the fat cells mainly, your fat cells are surrounding all your joint capsules, your brain is made up of all fat, not good.
So you end up storing these heavy metals, storing these toxins. And if all you did is store them, honestly you'd be fine.
You could live to 120 years old and it wouldn't cause any issues. What happens is that if your immune system turned on for some other reason.
Let's say I had a horrible flu or let's say I broke my leg so I have this huge immune response because of this injury.
Now I got all these marine core running through my blood looking for something to kill and let's say I sprayed my ankle really bad.
Well I didn't break the skin, I don't have any bacteria there. What is the swollenness of a sprayed ankle? That is all a TH1 response. Those are all lymphocytes.
So I got this huge TH1 response. Like we have injury here, we are called to the site, we got to kill, you know whatever, there are any bacteria, I didn't break the skin. The barrier wasn't broken.
So it fires this giant response so there's circulator on, well we got these guns and we got bullets and I want to use them.
So it could find something that it's not supposed to turn on against. Like mercury in your joint capsule and you start getting this pain in your joint and you can't figure out why.
Now what's your immune system turns on against something? It is relentless, it won't stop. So you're this constant ramped up inflammatory process.